how about Vegas dude Vegas was good UFC
296 it was a a good good card was how
close were you to the uh the fight
between oh my gosh actually so I'm in
every almost every single one of the
videos popping around cuz I was I
actually missed the jump I just heard a
bunch of commotion and my manager like
looked over my side of my shoulder and I
looked over and they and I saw I saw
Strickland had already thrown the
punches and now he was going elbows um
126 completely illegal
UniFi unified rules mixed martial arts
but in the crowd you can pretty much do
whatever you want it's a street fight
just get the kids out of the way they
actually did though did you hear about
that because it was it was Gilbert burns
his wife Bruna and their two boys were
just sweetest people in the world but
they were literally on the underneath
the freaking trajectory so they told him
to move and then they probably didn't
think nobody thought he was going to
actually jump over now that I watched
the videos but he did he's Sean
Strickland so dude Dana's response to uh
just the question or whatever about
about Sean Strickland politely asking
the kids to get out of the way it was so
funny man yeah I mean it is actually
hilarious because you know he it
actually kind of it's really kind of
cool because it shows a little bit of
self-awareness where he's like hey I
can't be trusted I know I know what I'm
about to do but let me at least uh just
tell you know and anybody else who was
like Hey move move move nothing will
actually happen but it's Sean Strickland
and that's why that's why we freaking
love him man like he's he's just a
freaking fun dude to watch he's uh he's
he's a wild card man um dude so I I saw
your Tweet um about Colby oh yeah uh you
said uh for a guy who talked what did
you well for a guy who talks about
everyone being triggered he sure was
afraid to pull the trigger and then I
also said if his if his offense tonight
was an accurate depiction of us strength
we would have never got gained our
independence Lost World War I and got
demoralized in World War II now I only
say that because I don't like to talk a
lot of trash and never do I ever want to
step on a guy when he's down after he
loses right cuz I hate when people do
that to me we all hate it but whenever
you've created such a fake character
like you've become the character it's
like well I'm not actually hating on Co
Covington the heartbeat the guy outside
of just fighting you're hating on the
character just like it's WWE and funny
thing is I just I think he crossed the
line I think he's a sure I just he's I
don't know he's not my style I think he
and I might actually agree on a decent
amount of things but I think his
delivery is just asinine so the line is
dead people well yeah I mean murdered
father and like yeah I mean what he said
about Leon what I mean and even I mean I
mean family in general oh for sure but
that yeah that was just one example and
he's just I mean I don't know it's but I
also I think it's uh for me a guy who I
just am who I am I don't really try to
play a character I mean yeah of course
every now and then you get pumped up
when you're on the microphone and maybe
you're a little bit more aggressive
a little bit more whatever but actually
playing a a character and you know just
it just doesn't sit well with me and I
just think he's the wrong I I don't buy
it anyway because uh yeah oh that you
know he's actually a sweet guy but like
does this
character if you're a sweet guy then
you're not like you know degrading
people you know yeah I mean there's
there's a line you won't cross you
there's a line you won't let your your
character cross you know just like just
like there be like actual actors who are
like hey I'm an actor and I'll do
anything in this fantasy world that we
call you know film but I have a certain
things that I I don't want to do on
camera or whatever like it's I don't
know it's uh yeah he and I are not I've
actually never spoken a word to the guy
but I do have mutual friends who are
like oh I swear he's a nice guy I'm like
maybe do you like shopping on Amazon I
do and good news is sto's butt wipes for
your butthole are available on Amazon
and if you want a real bundle of a deal
you can get sto's hot sauce for your
butthole plus sto's butthole destroyer
and steo butt wipes for your butthole
it's the butthole bundle available on
Amazon right
now yeah dude